well well well i think this makes
perfect sense and is something everyone
has actually been asking themselves over
the past like two months now
who in the world is the actual final
villain in tokyo avengers we got the
megalomaniac locomotive captain the
scarface wannabe harachio sanzu who
currently feels like the craziest dude
out there literally trying to send a
freaking train through the battlefield
and okay you're probably like devolo you
absolute egg it's obviously mikey he's
the captain of the stacked ass gang that
is the kanto margin gang and i'm like
well yeah that makes perfect sense
dude's out here murking people left
right and center and he doesn't actually
care about how he takes down or who gets
taken down in the first place honestly i
didn't want to say it in the last video
mikey's got this crazy ass sasuke vibe
going on right now with being bad just
for the sake of being bad for the story
or plot but obviously here i'm just
speaking out my ass because i don't know
actually what happens in the next few
chapters or what's going to happen in
the next few chapters but still that's
two guys who honestly could easily be
considered by themselves the final three
of the series but what about the other
dude who is constantly in every single
conflict bar one in the black dragon's
arc but still they end up betraying
takamichi so yes constantly in every
single conflict or battle throughout the
entire story the demon who seems to just
always be there preying on the downfall
of anyone for his own entertainment the
man with probably the most fitting
nicknames here's the reaper the most
well-known throughout this story as the
god of death shooji hanma so obviously
hey everyone dear volo here and in
today's video as i've just said we're
going to be going over the like final
villain or who i guess i think is the
final villain and kind of like some
theories uh as to what could happen in
this final battle here or like possibly
what could go down afterwards obviously
if you do enjoy this kind of content
make sure you hit that like button and
if you are new and here i want to keep
up to date with just this kind of tokyo
avengers content and other anime
explained content in general then make
sure you hit that subscribe button but
anyway enough of that let's get back
into the video so firstly i want to know
your thoughts on what you think the
outcome of the story is going to be down
in the comment section below do you
think it's going to end after this
battle or do you think it's going to
continue with more chapters leading into
another conflict recently i've had like
these questions just playing on repeat
and i truly don't know i've got a
feeling that if the series did end at
this point but the battle it would end
in a completely unforeseen way they're
literally no one but waikui knows about
obviously it's probably going to have
something to do with sanzu and the train
attack that takamichi like literally
just for saw as i shouldn't even need to
mention it but how did takamichi even
end up coming back to life in the first
place was it because he shook naoto's
hand and that kind of like flashback
memory that he had when that train was
heading towards him because technically
that doesn't even work takamichi should
have died on the tracks the pack they
made didn't exist when adult takamichi
initially got hit by the train so most
likely it's going to have something to
do with takamichi and himself shaking
someone's hand while in the past to
almost reset everything back to the
train crash point or like just before he
literally steps onto those tracks and
dies in a similar way to how i brought
it up in my theory the end of tokyo
avengers where i almost stupidly thought
that kazutora would be this person to
save the day obviously i don't think he
is escaping juvie anytime soon now and
getting out as i felt like he would have
shown up if he already did still though
maybe he might who actually knows the
ganks of waikui's way of thinking
quickly though if you ain't caught up
i'ma just hurt your souls really quick
with this information but i thought i
just had was that maybe the time
inception handshake that i love to bring
up could happen between takamichi and
kukucho like i know that absolute
piece of trash sanzu dude is like the
definition of weak and i'm a mould for
another second so this guy plays like
literally no part earlier on before the
tenshi quark then shows up and kills a
moot show and kikucho with a samurai
sword
know your place trash
like okay calm down at least kakuto is
getting a respectful death somewhat
unlike draken just being shot by a
complete random nobody like damn i'm
never actually going to be able to get
over there but anyway anyway as i
brought it up just before we really have
three juggernauts of antagonists that
takamichi is seemingly having to try and
defeat with a smaller force like it
really just doesn't seem slightly
capable even after our boys kikucho and
koko decided to switch back to
takamichi's side it's still so hard to
see a way where takamichi can actually
come out on top it isn't like the
tenjiku arc where mikey is just going to
show up and save the day for him because
obviously he won't chase sides the dude
is bad i doubt even if sansu and his
locomotive maneuver manages to work and
he kills a bunch of the original members
or even just the beloved members of
tomen i don't see anything changing with
his attitude it's like i said in my
theory months ago now right when i
started out making videos about how i
think the only way mikey is going to
realize the gravity of the situation is
to have takamichi actually die in a
serious ending that breaks all of our
hearts which to me is becoming more and
more likely with just how things are
shaping up does takamichi actually want
to live in a world where everyone else
is dead but mikey is alive and good yet
completely miserable due to what
happened so obviously i went off in a
slight tangent there but the idea is
still there in my eyes who out of these
three is the true final villain to me i
think it's the high possibility of being
hanma the guy lives off other's misery
which he turns into his own
entertainment he even says his life is
dull as and what kisagi had been
doing to other people's lives
entertained him he has always been
around like yes sanzu has as well but
what i think is important about hanuma
is that he usually and any chance he got
opposed to mikey and takamichi and for
all we know he could be manipulating
even sanzu in ways he wants so that it's
entertaining just for him like all of a
sudden in the story he shows back up on
mikey's side it just feels really
suspicious to me then of course earlier
on in the series a flashback kisaki had
where he said to hanma i'm not built to
be a main character i'm just a clown but
that won't stop me from getting what i
want dude funnily enough died like a
clown getting hit by truck corn and
becoming a complete and utter meme in
the community then later on at the
gravesides on a completely undisclosed
date and time i'm pretty sure we're
getting older honma or at least i think
he's much older with long hair smoking
at most likely kizaki's grave
though like as silly as it is i might as
well mention it because it's not
confirmed to be his grave i don't think
it is anyway the background behind hama
looks similar to where mikey went to pay
respect to his brother so maybe some
kind of connection there or just
coincidence but he sits down to tell the
story of the perot and the reaper
apparatus which you know obviously
excuse my pronunciation is a clown which
obviously refers to kisaki and then of
course the reaper refers to his early
nickname the reaper shooji hanma so
maybe this here is actually hanma coming
back and telling the story to someone's
grave about firstly hisaki's story and
then finally obviously his story after
it comes to an end or something i don't
know and there would obviously have to
be a bad ending for this to take place
in hanuma roll up to like a grave and
tell everyone the story of what happened
because he's still alive somehow and i'm
saying he's the bad dude so obviously
i'm thinking there's a bad ending coming
up because it really just feels that way
kind of like right now in any aspect it
feels like takamichi is to me just gonna
have to reset everything and go back to
that beginning of his life and kind of
be happy with what he had at least
that's that's how it's feeling to me
right now obviously this is all just
like a huge speculation and i don't
really know what could happen but i
usually enjoy looking at some of the
finer details and trying to find subtle
hurts at possible outcomes i've also
gotten over my grouch which i had with
the whole plane incident and have
managed to like kind of tell myself just
to focus on the bigger picture and get
back into the zone and obviously as
meant to as this final arc may seem i do
think that there is a good amount of
chapters left over and waiko is probably
not going to end the story until he
finds the ending he wants obviously
hence hence why the three deities arc or
i guess saginaw has turned into a saga
with the three deities not really having
much play of any at all on this arc
anymore
it's still around the 48-ish chapter
mark in this arc as well and the
tenshiku arc was like almost 90 chapters
from memory so i can see this uh going
for like much much longer and it's not
iot he doesn't need to end this on like
a specific number or anything like that
so he could drag this arc out for as
long as he needs or make more arcs until
he finds the ending that kind of he
wants exactly because this is his story
at the end of the day he's doing what he
wants either way as i said at the
beginning of the video i'd love to know
what you all think is going to happen
with the final villain and who it truly
is is it sanzu who seemingly came out of
left field to be the main antag or is it
the tokyo avengers sasuke edition mikey
or is it finally my favorite the goat of
death shuchihanma absolutely no
favoritism my mind when it comes to
hanuma but anyway if you are new around
here and want more content just like
this or manga explained content where i
go over arcs in far too much detail then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to try and push this
video to 2.5 k likes and i'll do a bunch
more stuff going over like tokyo
avengers characters and all that kind of
jazz in the future more theories but
anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all enable bye